hey here's a little story update for you
remember near the end of Roy Moore's
failed Senate campaign in Alabama where
he lost to Doug Jones of course Moore's
wife during a speech tried to defend
herself and Roy Moore against claims of
anti-semitism made against them by
saying that they have a Jewish lawyer
here's a clip just reminding you of what
that was like
might tell you all this because I've
seen it all so I just won't set the
record straight while they're here yeah
one of our attorneys is a Jew
more just look psychotic behind her as
she's delivering these lines one of our
attorneys is a Jew a dirty [ __ ]
money-grubbing moneylender Jew lawyer
that we have it sounds so tone-deaf
right as if a Jew is something exotic
well actually maybe in Alabama a Jew is
something exotic I don't know what the
Jewish population is there this
immediately became the new I'm not
racist I have black friends and by the
way pointing out that the one Jewish
person you know is a lawyer you've hired
is not exactly the most brilliant and
open-minded and enlightened defense but
anyway here's the news it turns out that
their Jew lawyer voted for mores
opponent doug jones his name is Richard
Jaffe and he defended Roy Moore son
against drug charges two years ago he's
been a friend of Doug Jones for 30 years
he raised money for Doug Jones he
donated for Doug Jones and in a way we
can kind of say Roy Moore funded Doug
Jones right Roy Moore pays Richard Jaffe
legal fees part of which Jaffe then
donates the Doug Jones it's pretty
brilliant and you know what maybe they
were right to be anti-semitic you just
can't trust these Jewish lawyers you
hire them you give them money and then
they take the money and donate it to the
other guy this is such a silly story in
how much it has just completely
backfired and it seemed a completely
harebrained way to try to defend
yourself against allegations of
anti-semitism every detail is hilarious
about this I hope they have another
response to allegations that they're
anti-semitic right because they can't
use this attorney as a Jew excuse
anymore no they can't they can't anymore
and I don't know what their next maybe
their what maybe their accountant is
Jewish as well they can focus on that
wonder who that guy voted for anyway I
think I can say that I'm very glad to
see the career the political career of
Roy Moore effectively ended do you agree
that this is the end of his political
career or do you think he might
resurface he's in his early 70s at this
point too it goes from here what could
he even run for at this point I don't
know